close is that are you guys coming up oh
you got beer on the course I'll take a
beer and let them make Jordan cleats hot
I go once every three years but frozen
I'm frozen snicker bars I'll take about
six of those up oh wow you have a nice
[ __ ] happy hour well now I got a
chill I went to one this corporate one
who's so bad in Florida and the girls
who are handing out drinks were topless
there's girls there okay the card girls
are usually always hot they're always
had their high and it was a thing I
guess it was sponsored by playboy some
[ __ ] I was like how are ya it's out
yeah can we get you a drink I was like
all right you're embarrassed what bad
life decision did you make we're on hole
seven with your tits out I'm handing me
a bag of Cheetos and then all these fat
corporate guys who are like what I do to
get so many tried because they were like
kind of you guys least you guys aren't
hot huh
as I'm as in the temperature and there's
old fat guys just has no filter
sun's out tits out girls stupid things
like the brunette looks dirty
she looks dirty yeah
she's dirty is she all right I've I've
I've been with a girl like that that
blonde that blonde with those tits yeah
tits
I'm telling you all you got to do man
this what you do is this what I did
advise so you were 300 pounds sir with
writing kids break out your pocketbook
yeah unless she's a professional you're
not touching her the only reason she's
talking you just trying to slang this
[ __ ] Baby Ruth to your fat ass right
it's the only this snicker bar and shut
up and smile I'm a smile and I'm gonna
have the worst swing on the course then
we get balls deep with her on the back
nine we going back my favorite guys to
spend a fortune on clubs and they got
the ball washers and they got all kinds
oh [ __ ] you Alyssa names Tiger Woods get
on I'll look the part though just real
aware in when you're hitting mitts with
them it's not like you're doing artists
do one two three four and that goes do
it again let's do it again it's more
fight reactive you know reaction time
kind of stuff and hating combos as soon
as you hold them up and in
you back and holding you in good
position so I was brilliant me yeah he's
good and he's a guy who I think he
deserves more credit but he doesn't want
it no you don't see him when one of his
fighters win jumped up and down like
Provo at Perot boxing.com or whatever
you know like yeah it's just he's always
back you know he's behind the scenes
yeah but what he's done with Bisbing
cyborg I'm such a fan of the guy yeah I
mean so doing saw the opening in Luke
Rockhold like most before the fight
happened to and I'm talking to pearl and
also seeing the fight go down I've seen
Perillo like showing like that was the
left toe goes Tony that was the left
hook because Rocco kept dropping his
right hand every time he threw across
every time he threw his own cross he
would drop his right hand completely and
you know pearl it was good at seeing
those things but yeah cuz rock walls
posts and videos of sparring of hitting
mitts all up to his fight a bunch of
them you know and like you were able to
see exactly what he does like his
tendencies like all those all those bad
habits he has and you were able to game
plan for that and so to have a coach is
able to see that like Dwayne seen it and
so did Perillo it so I could see they're
both kind of really into that like OCD
pick apart your opponent see the
openings they saw the opening they took
advantage of it you know and with with
doing all this out here how's Dwayne
feel about it he's supportive man he
wants me to do it he's the one that like
told me like I need to start working
with other guys you know you don't get
uncomfortable getting put in these
positions positions so that you know I'm
not a camp right now you know I'm able
to do these learning curves and to work
with new people he's very supportive of
it because he cares about me you know he
cares about me as an athlete who ain't
cares about like my growth and he knows
by me learning from everyone I mean
obviously if someone's full of crap he's
gonna tell me he's like yeah that guy's
full of [ __ ] don't you working with the
best the best and he knows that you know
and so he's very very supportive and
he's pushed me out here to do it which I
it it just shows that you made the right
decision going with Dwayne because for
those lists of how that done those sport
it's very very uncommon for a coach go
yeah go do that yeah cuz they're so
worried because you know they want the
credit or they don't want their fighter
changing up or doing something that's
out of their you know kind of money in
their pocket you know say for some
reason I came down here fell in love
with the training and told Duane like
I'm moving you know see you man yeah so
like a lot of a lot of trainers will
don't let guys train other places or
they have big ego they wanted to secure
big man on campus and they won't let you
do it but I'm around great people you
know I'm around Duane Ludwig that wants
me to move around
Elliot Marshall that that you know
learns from everyone Elliot Marshall
when I go and learn from a new coach and
I come back and I teach it to him he
like he he'll absorb it to his style if
he likes it well I came in and of much
better
I was already established doing
something else and and like slowly built
up to every place I guess but like like
I'm resetting at one point he's working
on that Judd Apatow movie the stand-up
movie which I forget the funny people
wonderful flick so Seth goes uh you know
I had to go up on stage in advance of
the movie to prep and stuff so you know
we went and did comedy gigs and whatnot
and he's like and I realized that first
seven eight minutes I'm just cruising on
a it's it's him he's been in movies he's
gone but about after that man if you're
not [ __ ] funny they will let you know
[ __ ] who you are that's right I've
always not worried about that I was my
mother said why does that happen to
Michael Richards he'd get on stage if
Kramer from from Seinfeld yeah and he
would get on stage and people were like
yeah but Michael Richards wasn't a comic
but Michael Richards had been doing
stand-up Michael Richards wonderful
actor but not not a comic well so they
work on the right but he was it right
not really not from what I could tell
and he would get up there so he decided
I'm gonna try to do stand-up and you
know and take my performance very good
performer but it just would get quiet in
five minutes and I mean quiet really bad
to the point where I just couldn't watch
and in fact the night that he had that
incident yeah I had closed I had closed
the earlier show right know that laughs
actresses next guy Rogan was at the
improv you're at the the next guy on
stage after me I believe was Michael and
I remember and I had a bad experience
because and I've worked with him since
he's great but then I don't think he's a
racist I think he what happened was he
started to have another one of those bad
sets and I remember I went I gotta get
out of here cuz I don't want to watch
him not do well well I just didn't want
to see it's uncomfortable the crowd so
excited questions yeah if if you're
even a bad set or do you have to hang in
there I believe if you having a bad set
you know look I've been doing it so long
that I have such a bag of tricks that
I'm not gonna have a bad set right I
just I got too much you can bring out
the old me I'm always overly prepared
yeah sometimes the audience is just not
listening to your music right and I
think what you have to do then is slow
down not speed up a lot of people speed
of you slow down you kind of acknowledge
what's going on and then you just kind
of I guess just yet you butt-licker
yeah yeah you just start you just kind
of like have to go hey guys this is how
it goes if I have to slow down and do my
jokes I've done that I when I did a joke
and they didn't laugh cuz they were I
was starting to lose them they were just
in this mood and I did the joke again
but I did it deliberately you guys
didn't get this hold on let me try it
again
you know they're they're waste for me I
mean I am I think but but you didn't
have that to that so what happened was
there was a black guy who started to
heckle him who was up there and and and
him and he yeah and he he decided to
start dropping n bombs which of course
of course
you never do under any circumstances
because it's not forget all the races
stuff it's also just me